[Music]
coming up next on book notes it's a look
at the life of cuban leader fidel castro
our guest is syndicated columnist
georgie ann guyer author of gorilla
prince the untold story of fidel castro
in this book she examines castro's early
political influences his rise to power
and the effect of his policies on cuba
today
as part of the research for the book
georgie ann guyer interviewed fidel
castro four times
she now shares her observations of the
cuban leader on book notes
georgian guyer author of the book
gorilla prince the untold story of fidel
castro
why another book on cuba and castro
well brian there really were almost no
good biographies of castro and that's
why i started it because here is this
man who has had a most incredible
incredible influence on the united
states and on the world on the third
world on our policy on the soviets and
yet
having read almost everything
on latin american on the charismatic
leaders
you i couldn't find anything that told
me
who was fidel castro and so i
engaged in the search about seven years
ago
and started searching the world for
people who knew him and books and
in spanish and portuguese and german and
uh just about everything that could
answer that question for me
500 interviews 500
original interviews in 28 countries
it's a lot of work can you pick one of
those interviews that you'll remember
the most
oh there's so many i remember i remember
searching for there was
looking at his personal life there was a
young woman that he was engaged to in
mexico now fidel castro didn't not often
get engaged i mean that you know that
sort of institutional respectable
uh
arrangement was not the kind of thing
that he went for he was married once
between 48 and 53 divorced so this young
woman her name was in the book in one
book was called lilia
so i said who is lily and i asked a
cuban who knew them in miami and he said
no her name is isabel custodio i knew
her so whereas she said i don't know but
her father was
a republi a spaniard from the republic
and he went to mexico of course against
franco
so i found the republican
club in mexico city
they knew where isabel custodio's father
was in spain
when i went to spain i went to see mr
custodio a charming elderly gentleman he
told me where isabel was
and so i'd have to say i had a friend
and then interviewer because i was not
in mexico but that kind of a search is
very engaging and that kind of an
interview once you get it
is is just priceless you feel like you
just you've just hit gold did you tape
them all
yes we taped everything so there would
be no no question in people's minds all
those audio tapes i hid them
i'm going to keep them until at least
until the book is several years
into into itself into its printing or i
may just give them to one of the
universities in their libraries but they
will be kept so no one can ever question
the information you speak spanish i
speak fluent spanish portuguese and
german and some russian when was the
last time you interviewed fidel castro
well brian i did not interview him since
1966 and i'm very clear about that in
the book i'm not trying to make it
appear that this book had any
collaboration because although i tried
very hard it did not and you know it
took me a little while to figure out
that
men like fidel castro leaders like him
you see they don't want to collaborate
with anybody and they never do
because they have to remain secretive
in order to hold their power they have
to remain unknown
and once i understood that then i didn't
worry about the lack of collaboration
when was the last time you were in cuba
66
how old is fidel castro vidal is 64 now
which is as you know not old today at
all but he
that's an early picture of him when he
in his christ-like early years when he
took havana that's the way he looked and
then later today he has that crazy look
the white beard his mannerisms have
gotten crazy he
he always waved his arms but now there's
a
now he's he's degrading the the cuban
people before he used to be wooing them
and loving them and teaching them
and now that's fidel today
he's berating them he's he's blaming
them because his grandeur did not
uh was not fulfilled and so who does he
blame he blames the cuban people how
long is he going to last
my my rough judgment brian would be
about two years
nobody knows of course the man has been
ill he's had a heart attack he's had
some kind of cancer
he could be assassinated easily not
easily but he could be assassinated
but i would think
that given the horrors of his regime
today they're really they're out of food
they're
he buys sugar on the world market to
fulfill his quota to the russians he
can't even
raise sugar on a sugar island he's
moving people back to the countryside
they are breeding rats to eat for people
to eat breeding them
and so i can't imagine even with his
secret police and even with his
intelligence
that he could stay more than two years
raoul his brother where is he rose there
he's the the epigon
brother little brother
uh but he is he's been named his
successor but rel is not
uh is not popular and rel has no
charisma
and
there's rel when they took havana
remember those wonderful days you know
that's it's so sad that this happens to
revolutions
kind of uh
guy is his brother and what's he do now
do you know yeah rebels is the defense
minister he's head of the army he is the
soviets man in havana
uh raul is different he's um he's much
more tight
he's much more intellectual fidel is not
intellectual and not ideological raul is
ideological he was a communist party
member in the early days
fidel was never a communist and he's not
today a communist he is a fidelista he
believes in himself
and darrell interestingly enough was
much more of a family man
he cared about his children but his
parents their parents he cared about
fidel's children fidel doesn't care
about he anybody in the family
and fidel is a cold austere remote
disciplining punishing
type of man he's
he really i couldn't find
in all of the work i did that
he ever cared for any one person except
perhaps the one woman in his life celia
sanchez who was
very
she was a lover earlier in his life in
the sierra and later made herself just
indispensable to him
you write up a lot about some of the
interviews that have already been
conducted on american television maria
shriver's interview barbara walters i
think dan rather lots of others why do
so many american
television journalists make a path to
cuba and talk to him and why does he
talk to them
that's a good question brian i it's it's
the it's the revolutionary hero
you know 90 miles from our shores it's
uh it's the fidel that came into havana
in the early first week of january
of 1959 riding on a tank with
all of these barbudos who were supposed
to be the pure men of the mountains you
know and they were simple good pure men
against the terrible old decadent men of
batista
and he's
he's endlessly innovative in terms of
power you know his mannerisms when i was
with him i'd watch his face because
he'll be very ingratiating one moment
and he'll kind of make faces and his
eyes will roll and he uses his hands in
kind of odd ways
and he'll punch you on the on the
shoulder and eat your canapes and things
like that he's always good for a story
and he is fidel regardless of what
anybody thinks of him was the quote
revolutionary hero unquote of the modern
age
he was the there's nobody that that that
comes up to him
and so naturally journalists like that
kind of figure and he is brilliant i
mean he's on the media manipulating the
media and images and myths of the modern
world
so he knows exactly whom he wants in
havana
and where he can get the best display
for his talents on american television
he should be studied
we're spending a lot of money in this
country you can tell us the figure on tv
martini and radio marti what are those
two and and why are we doing that
well brian radio marty went into effect
about seven years ago with congressional
authorization and
it was amazing that it went through
because we already have voice of america
we have radio for europe toward eastern
europe but this was a radio directed
only at cuba in spanish not even not in
english
and
purportedly to bring news
of the world another voice if you will
to cuba
which is has been tremendously isolated
and tremendously cut off and it did very
well until about a year ago when it got
to be much more politicized by some of
the cuban factions in miami
tv martial is just in a trial stage they
just okay the congress okayed 16 million
dollars for it
but it's not really reaching cubits
reaching
only the havana area about from about
three to six in the morning
so right now
tb marty is not is not doing much at all
do you think those
both those things work at all do they
matter radio marti certainly worked for
a long time
uh until as i say about a year ago when
you see the cuban community in miami
started to get very even more
politicized particularly more
conservative elements
and thinking that fidel because he's
failed so terribly
thinking that he was going to suddenly
go go down very quickly and they were
going to go back and take power
so they began using radio mrt which was
which is really too bad
but it's also very foolish because
there's no way that exiles or
expatriates are going to be the ones who
will rule cuba in the future even in the
post-castro era why
well first of all brandon never happens
anyplace in the world
uh more important than that is but now
has been in power for 32 years
and you know since 1959 and this is a
very different cuba he's cut it off from
the united states from the western world
he's faced it toward the communist world
but they don't belong to it
these are very different people it's
much more of a black country it was
about 20 25 percent black cuban and 59
now it's closer to 40 45
the cubans today who have been on the
island are not going to welcome
upper class
white
cubans from miami who haven't been there
for 30 years as their next political
ruling class you know it just it just
doesn't make sense
10 million people about 10 million today
and you say that over a million and one
way or the other are at least reachable
to be under arms with the reservists and
all that even more than that i think
it's about a million and a half there
because fidel is
patel is a military man you know he and
franco were great friends nobody knows
that everyone thinks francisco franco of
spain was a fascist dictator of the
right fidel is a
a collective marxist strong man of the
left but actually they they were two
guerrilla fighters with the spanish
blood
uh of the conquistadores and the
inquisition and in their in their soul
uh so
you know that that is where fidel
belongs in in the whole spectrum
you've uh
because we talked chatted before where
we went on you've been on the tour where
have you been
well so far i've been just to see new
york cincinnati philadelphia
washington then i'm going to
boston back to washington miami chicago
indianapolis
dallas los angeles
and if i survive all of that ryan
you may see me back again what's the
thing people first ask you about
well it's interesting because they asked
me what i was asking when i was writing
when i'm starting the book
they ask me what is he like
they always ask me one of the first
questions and interesting they say was
he ever married
and that's a perfectly natural question
that's what you want to know about
people you know what is his or her
personal life like
and cubans brian do not know that he was
married
it's an extraordinary picture of him
with his wife look at how handsome they
were how beautiful
that was taken at the united fruit
company town where she was from she was
upper class father was a lawyer for
united fruit and on puerto rico beach
which he hated because it was
americanized
but look at that you know how happy and
of course how miserable they were later
and how miserable he made her life and
her name is murtaugh
diaz-balart where does she live now she
remarried they were divorced in 53.
she remarried a very conservative cuban
and they live in madrid have two
daughters and you know fidel is a study
though he when he wanted to get rid of
mirta after about 19 they were married
in 48 and in 53 he was in jail for this
attack in the montana barracks
and
i talked to oh eight or nine men who
were in the political prison with him
and they all said to me
when
one of the
things we really knew in prison was you
don't write to your wife and your
mistress on the same day
because there's a censor and he's a very
nice man but he he was he would get
letters confused
and so what did fidel do of course he
wrote to his wife and mistress on the
same day the letters were confused mirta
got the mistresses letter and
that was sort of the final thing they
got to forrest
who's in this picture that's his his one
legitimate son fidelito by his marriage
to mirta
where is he
he is in cuba now he's head of a nuclear
facility
uh he was russian trained lived in
russia for a long time had a pseudonym
as he studied married a russian woman
and they have three daughters
and even he brian
even until five years ago
no one knew fidelito
publicly and only then for reasons that
we don't know did vidalito come out in
the press did fidel allow him
to come out
who's this
that's his his daughter alina by the his
beautiful paramore and mistress nadi
rawalta
she was his mistress she was the one
that he wrote the other letter to
in the jail and alina his daughter by
nanty is as you can see a real
counter cultural counterculture daughter
and she does not like her father and she
raves at him and she wants to leave the
island and he's had a lot of trouble
with his children did you get this
information is it readily available or
do you have to
you know scrap for it you have to really
scrap for it ryan
the thing there are people all over the
world who have known fidel at different
points
neighbors of his when he was growing up
neighbors of mirta his wife
uh people who were with him at the
jesuit high school who were with him
afterwards in the political fights
people from the press in cuba people who
are coming out defectors and i just went
doggedly from one to the other and
interviewed them in great depth and then
you'd hear suddenly someone
a young man came out a couple years ago
who was a good friend of elena's i
talked to him
um then in this one of the spanish
papers did an article on her there were
pictures of her for the first time i saw
her and then you know you just put it's
like putting an incredible puzzle
together and you never feel like you've
got enough
but you got so much more than anybody
had before
that it makes it worthwhile tell us
about this picture and
when was it taken
that was taken in the spring of uh 88
when mikhail gorbachev went to havana
they're ostensibly signing one of the
treaties then but that's a misleading
picture because they did not get along
at all on that trip in fact fidel
already hated gorbachev
because he was liberalizing because he
was a tremendous threat to cuba and a
threat to
continued aid to cuba within the soviet
union
mr gorbachev gave a speech while he was
there and talked i mean as i remember
you you're right that
said some things that fidel castro would
do soon to not say to them
both of them just insulted each other
but fidel was much worse because fidel
introduced garbage up and took more time
than gorbachev even had for his speech
this was in the national assembly and in
introducing him fidel talked about
stalinism all the time
of course what gorbachev just hates to
hear talk about stalinism and reminders
of stalin's days and then when gorbachev
spoke that he talked about
an end to aid for central america and
for the guerrillas and of course that
was before changes in nicaragua and of
course that was fidel's baby
so you had the two of them insulting
each other to a point at which when when
gorbachev left he came into havana in an
open car with fidel he left in a closed
car with even the curtains closed
so no one could see him and
when fidel was asked afterwards why did
mr gorbachev leave in a closed car
fidel said he was afraid he would catch
a cold
how much money does the soviet union
provide cuba today six billion dollars a
year still still
they're cutting back but we don't have
exact figures yet they're going to cut
back there's no question relations are
very chilly but you see the soviet
military still has a great interest in
cuba
as a listening post for soviet
intelligence about the united states
so cuba will indeed be the last
colony surrogate of the soviets in in
the world i mean they've already they're
abandoning angola ethiopia mozambique
vietnam
but cuba will be the last ones so this
gives fidel a little more time too how
many soviet uh military personnel in
cuba it changes from minute to minute
probably about three thousand now and
they do control the missiles
what kind of armament is there
they have a lot of
electronic listening posts they have a
big base in san fuegos they have they
control the missiles which they gave
have given him for protection
a whole lineup of things which are not
that obvious to the cuban people
you have a rundown of the number of
cuban soldiers that are in these
different countries 57 000 troops or
were in in angola
five to seven thousand in ethiopia
hundreds and thousands from south yemen
to uh libya to nicaragua mozambique
syria ecuadoria
guinea
and goes on and on why cubans all over
the world
well brian that that's what's so
extraordinary about castro
and i don't mean extraordinary in a
desirable way but in a as a power study
fidel castro took this little island
with basically no economy except sugar
he's destroyed that and he created power
out of this powerlessness and power on a
world stage those were the figures in
those countries at the height of
his his guerrilla power his his
imperialist power if you will
when he went into angola in 1974 i mean
he moved thousands of troops across the
atlantic for the first time in history
troops were going across the atlantic
not from the united states but from this
little island in the caribbean
he's an incredible military man but he
can't do anything else
and everything in cuba is so militarized
it's not communist it's not collectivist
it's not marxist
it is pure
third world military
and
if you admire military power and the
mind that goes behind that then fidel
castro is a very interesting man where
are there troops cuban troops today
anyway they're basically all coming home
you see the 57 58 000 troops that were
in angola
are mostly home now
and that's his big problem the other
countries are also always also clearing
out his big problem brian is these 57 58
000 cubans come home from angola
there is no economy to absorb them there
are no jobs and two years ago he
executed the hero of angola general
arnaldo ochoa
this very
excellent military office an officer a
quintessentially honorable man handsome
long beak nose had served in ethiopia
and goa
nicaragua
very loyal to fidel but you see arnaldo
ochoa did something terrible he became a
competitor
to fidel and he never
never ever allows anyone to become a
competitor he moves them out he kills
them puts them in prison puts them under
house arrest whatever is the appropriate
thing and the only appropriate thing in
fidel's mind for arnold ochoa was to be
executed
you see those films of that
trial of ochoa which was now two years
ago this spring
it's just
chilling because you could see the men
there were four of them that were
executed together
you could see them in this
moscow type of trial from the 30s
they did they looked down they wouldn't
look up some of them just broke down on
the stands you could see how false the
whole thing was
and it's it's a very chilling surreal
kind of place
let me ask you some things about the
book
why the name gorilla prince
well there was a lot in there about the
guerrilla movements because i i that's
been an interest in mine and we've
traced that over the years i've traced
it over the years in the book and i
lived in the mountains in guatemala once
with the marxist gorillas for a week
and so we wanted gorilla somewhere in
the title
and then i wanted i played with it and i
wanted something jarring or something
dissident dissonant
and i thought prince because
gorilla and prince don't go together and
yet it brings in machiavelli and fidel
is
an incredibly machiavellian
thinker
and people people seem to like the the
title
because it's it's different it's it's
it's strange
did where'd the photo come from and um
did you choose it
no i didn't take that uh the the
publisher got that i don't know where
they got that
and on the back uh they have praise for
guerrilla prince from four individuals
one of them is big new brzezinski
william colby
paul duke and major florentino espilago
did you have anything to do with that
and why would and why were those four
chosen well i chose them
excuse me i thought brzezinski is one of
our foremost political thinkers at the
time
paul duke is the moderator of my show
washington week in review
bill colby was head of the cia during
much of the
of the castro years
and
in many ways brian the most interesting
one is florentino espiaga and what he
says because he was the highest level
cuban intelligence defector head of the
whole czechoslovakian
cuban intelligence at that time and when
i met him out in a cia station
house in the western suburbs i
introduced myself and he said oh i know
who you are
and i said well how and he said we used
to have home meetings of the cuban
intelligence about you and your book
and i said what did you discuss and he
said oh how to steal it how to copy it
how to get it
what was your mind set
and that was kind of chilling too i went
home that day and got a couple of boxes
at the bank and put everything in the
safety boxes
where is he now
he's around he's pretty much uh in
hiding in hiding or just not in public
but he's he's around washington how long
has he been in the united states he's
been here oh about five years now what
was his reason for leaving
the usual
you know they couldn't stand the system
anymore he wanted to get his children
out
how did he get out he walked out from
czechoslovakia literally to vienna
and the correct way pronounced says
major florentino aspiaga yes
and this book is published by little
brown uh you've written a number of
books why did you choose this publisher
well i think little brown is
unquestionably one of the very very top
publishers in this country
um and in a very strange publishing
market brian as you know where
everything is consumer oriented and the
big big companies are taking over the
publishing houses little brown is one of
the
more old style
houses that cares about good
writing they did the manchester
biographies for instance
uh their they know biography
uh so i'm very i'm very proud of little
brown did you always publish your books
through little brown no my others were
the first two were double day then an
educational publisher and then delacorte
and the other books include the new
latins the new 100 years war the young
russians
buying the night flight the
autobiography of a woman foreign
correspondent
which one of those other books did you
enjoy the most
i think i enjoyed the last one because
it was about me
when did you write it
it was written seven years ago
you uh dedicated this to your brother
glenn whose own rich creative spirit
love and support over so many years gave
me the confidence and security to write
this book tell us about your brother
glenn well he's a wonderful wonderful
guy he's 10 years older than i am
and
was always sort of a surrogate father to
me in addition to my own wonderful
father our wonderful father but glenn
always taught me creative things how he
was he's a very fine artist he still
lives in chicago and was a clothes
designer for many years wonderful
talent and just you know when i was a
little kid taught me how to
to hula dance and to sing and i used to
follow him around like a little puppy
and he'd say to my mother did she have
to go with me all the time you know
those terrible little sisters that was
me
where did you grow up chicago south side
of chicago
where did you go to school i went to
public schools to calumet high school
and then i went to northwestern
journalism and history and then i had a
fulbright to the university of vienna
and then when did you first get into the
writing business i started right after
that with the chicago daily news as a
society reporter because that's where
the only place women could start and
then i became
one of the first women regular reporters
and then one of the very first woman
foreign correspondent in our times there
were a couple much earlier
you have any idea where you got the
interest in being a foreign
correspondent
well yeah i do ryan i think um
there were there were a lot of creative
people in our family they're not
educated like my grandfather who came
from germany when he was 16
really had a lot of artistic talent he
was never educated
into it but but
it was it was there in a lot of members
of our family and my mother particularly
encouraged that she also encouraged me
to to read a lot when i was a child
and our family was very adventurous i
mean in a very limited way because we
didn't have money or anything my father
had a small dairy business but we travel
around the united states and i remember
we would always be looking for things my
my brother and i but also my parents you
know the corn palace in iowa or or some
little battleground and we we
they gave us a tremendous
little passions for seeing everything in
the world and i really think that's
where it started
i saw him in this country and then i
read maps and i remember once i was
looking at the holy land as it was
called then and i saw jerusalem and
i was breathless because i thought
jerusalem was something my sunday school
teacher
had made up
you know and there it was it was really
a place and so that was sort of it was a
kind of innocent but impassioned
background about trying to know the
world
which my my parents encouraged i think
later they got a little nervous about it
they didn't realize i was going to carry
it so far if you had to pick a spot a
foreign spot that you'd go to
that has the most interesting story
where is it today
you know i have i have a special
favorite which most people wouldn't
there's no reason they would know about
it but it's the sultanate of oman
the bottom of saudi arabia a wonderful
wonderful country
and i wanted to go there for a long time
because sultan caboose the president
sultan who has done a magnificent job
the country is just beautiful beautiful
oriental architecture boulevards parks
beautiful beaches and he took over from
his father he overthrew his father
in 1970 the father was an old curmudgeon
who kept people he had slaves he kept
people in absolute medieval poverty the
place was the most backward place on
earth and today it is one of the most
advanced
and i love
i love the romance of places like that i
love the history and i love good leaders
like that who have brought their people
not like saddam hussein just torture and
torment and punishment but really
brought them into the best of the 20th
century do you ever have any close calls
oh yeah yeah i was well i was held in by
the palestinians once in beirut
as a they thought i was the israeli
blonde who had led the raid on beirut in
1973. they didn't have any other blocks
so i was i was it
that was about six hours i was held
overnight in angola
in 76 because they they thought that
that i knew about a soviet coup against
the marxist mpla government there i
didn't but you know it was a perfect
shot while trying to escape
uh situation i was in the mountains in
guatemala in 66 with the marxist
gorillas for a week surrounded by
guatemalan troops all the time a brutal
army who would just you know
soon shoot you as look at you
i was in the nicaraguan airport in 82
when the early contrast blew it up
and we were
about two steps away from going into the
main part of the airport where everybody
was killed
so yeah but it's never when you think
it's going to be you know i i didn't go
to salvador that time because there was
terrible fighting i thought i've seen
enough of this i'll go to nicaragua and
then they blew up the airport in
nicaragua did you ever say uh i've you
know i've done this one once too many
times i better get out of this business
yeah yeah i've said it many times why
are you still doing it then well there's
nothing in the world that's as exciting
and it's fun and it's intellectually
stimulating
and i think idealistically
fulfilling because if you can write
something about another place and other
people and make your own country and
your own people understand better
and have an awful lot of fun as you go
along
i mean it's a it's an ideal way for
crazy people to live not for nice people
not for normal people when did you start
your column
started the column 15 years ago in 1975.
and when you write a column this may be
too personal and if it is just tell me
to bug off but when you write a column
do you have to pay your expenses when
you run around the world or to
so it all comes out of the out of my
earnings i can do anything i want but i
got to pay for it but that's not
personal at all
is it is the business of writing
remunerative enough i blew that one i
mean can you make enough money today to
make it worthwhile
yes but only with a lot of planning i
live i live nicely i don't make a
fortune
i have to work all the time i mean i
with this book it's been seven years six
years of 16 hour days seven days a week
and
that's too much
but people like me
i mean i have a wonderful syndicate
universal press syndicate and they're
very generous but you still in order to
do these travels which is very expensive
you have to do a lot of other things and
what most of us do brian is as we we
make additional money through speaking
give speeches to a lot of wonderful
groups and people around the country
it's perfectly legitimate it's perfectly
legal it's perfectly wonderful because
without that
you couldn't
have these independent voices which i
think
the the syndicated columnists are and i
think are valuable voices
because
literally nobody can tell me what to
write
and i must say i was absolutely right on
this war from start to finish
and that kind of the gulf war yes and
that kind of independence i think plays
a real role in journalism what do you
mean you were right
well i i i took the president's side in
the beginning because it seemed like
absolutely
the right
place
uh
not like vietnam which was just
a foolish
wanton wasteful conflict it was the sin
of a rich country
but this made sense because the reasons
were right that we can't let one country
take over another small country
two-thirds of the world's oil terrible
weapons that saddam had etc then i said
from the very beginning
there's not going to be an uprising of
the have-nots in the arab world
and i was right because if there had
been this would have turned out very
very differently
and i brought to it my i brought to 22
years of working in the middle east if
you don't have that you can't you can't
go over there and find those things out
i said the iraqi army is not is going to
it's going to collapse
in just a very few days well how did i
know that because i was out with the
iraqi army on the front lines in 84.
i mean i when people were building them
up into these superman i said hey wait a
minute it's still a very primitive
country they're completely defensive
they're completely passive they never
strike out
and and saddam can't count on them
particularly the ones in the south and
that's exactly what happened
so so and i said our army looks terrific
and they were going to do a wonderful
job
how did you get picked up i don't know
if that's the right word for washington
week in review
well actually it was through my dear
late friend peter lisagar and of course
peter and i had been on the same paper
that she got wonderful old chicago daily
news for years peter was head of the
washington bureau and when i moved here
in 75 he talked to paul duke it was his
idea
and
asked paul to try me out and so
we didn't it was a very happy marriage
and it's a wonderful show and
paul keeps us all very honest
and
it's i've been on it since 75 actually
how do you rotate we see you some weeks
don't see others
well it's i'm problematic o'brien
because i'm out of the country and i'm
out of the city so much you have to be
here on friday night first of all and i
haven't been here much and i've been
working on this book
but it depends upon what story you're
covering that week you know if i'm
covering say the golf politics from here
or if i've just come back from somewhere
that's what i'll usually be on and paul
will say well gigi that's my nickname
i'll say gigi's back from nicaragua
gigi's back from the gulf and that's
sort of my role i'm the one that comes
back from places
when you go out to speak
you're working on the book it's about
fidel castro that a lot of people aren't
talking about right now right and you're
writing all these columns about the gulf
how do you keep it all straight and how
do what's your approach to an audience
when you go out and speak to them well
yeah keep it straight that that's been a
problem the last six years because it's
it's very different writing a column
which you can do right in a couple of
hours of course the research for a lot
of as you know lots of things go into it
research over years sometimes
but it's a piece of journalism that's
here and it's finished in a couple of
hours and you're free of it the book
you're never free particularly it's a
total different
mindset i mean it's i sometimes felt i
was just being torn in so many
directions then i go out and i get on a
plane and i'm working on the book on the
plane and then i get say to
to
oklahoma city and i've got a speech
there before some nice group of people a
town hall or a foreign policy group
sometimes men's groups which is
interesting they want women you know
women speakers these days
and then you have to turn your mind
around again
and mix with people and socialize and
learn about them and
and try to give them a speech that's not
boring that's humorous that's serious
that doesn't insult their intelligence
because these are intelligent people or
they wouldn't have speakers
and
and be up you've got to be up you know
you've got to have energy and that was
the problem when i was doing this book
the energy levels were not that high so
you just got to force yourself to have
energy
and it's you know you do it all the time
in the book we'll go back to it
time really goes fast in this thing uh
since this is your writing since this
book was a intensely psychological
what's psychological about this book
i think
a lot of the book most of the book is
very psychological i talked to a lot of
psychiatrists about fidel i put quotes
from them in i never made a judgment
though on what kind of a psyche this man
has because that's much too complicated
i'm a journalist i'm not a psychiatrist
but what i tried to show
above all was how he
wove the spell
over the cuban people
also over individuals as you say like
american journalists american
activists
europeans
and i was trying to go in what is the
spell the exchange
of power so that that picture of the
masses in the
in the in the plaza in in
in havana that's where he gets his
energy that's where he gets his love
it's a tremendous exchange going on
there when they shout for him
that's where he gets his sustenance and
his love and when he
teaches them and talks to them
that's where they get it but then
i mean you stood there away 66 and
listened to him for 10 hours exactly
why would anybody do that well that's
what started me on this i you know i was
up with the foreign guests we were in a
comfortable place we could go in and out
we could talk we could chat or we could
go out and get a beer
but the
masses of cubans in the plaza they
couldn't leave at all they stood there
for nine ten hours
listening in the hot sun all day
and that was what i wanted to figure out
why was that going on does he keep
talking constantly for 10 hours
constantly does he have a script
no he doesn't he when he was younger and
i traced this uh he used to he spoke
from notes
but
by the time he came to power
it's like something gets going in him
like this passion gets going and he gets
up there and
he's just telling people everything
and
teaching them and admonishing them and
sometimes amusing them
and then they would say to me over and
over
well fidel would start to talk and
suddenly he was saying
he was saying what i have always thought
and you know and this is the exchange
it's like he's defining the world for
them and now that exchange run i am
convinced is is diminishing when was the
last time you know that he had
a major speech like this well he has
them all the time
but what we see what we see in the films
from cuban television what people tell
us
is that people aren't they're paying
attention anymore
see that's the that's the fidel of today
berating the people
telling them they've disgraced him they
haven't followed him that's the fidel of
today unlike the padel of yesterday
anybody else in the world do that kind
of thing 10 hours at a time absolutely
absolutely and that was one of the most
interesting things for me hitler a lot
like fidel i'm not saying fidel's a nazi
we're talking you know about tactics and
about the
the tactics the mechanisms that these
kinds of charismatic leaders
use
hitler was very similar in that mass
psychosis if you will mussolini fidel
used to give he he got an early tape
recorder one of those ones with a single
wire
and he would give mussolini's speeches
for hours in front of a mirror
standing there so he could learn those
the way that mussolini created the crowd
and there's a quote in there somewhere
from from mussolini when he's which is
very telling he says
he loved talking to the mobs the masses
in the plaza because they were like clay
in his hands and that's what these men
live for is to take this clay
of the people and not to free it
or not to
to
to make it more but to make it less to
make it their clay and to put their
stamp on it
and that's what really horrifies me
you say in the book that then you just
mentioned how one of the liner notes
talks about how they try to get this
book and all the contents away from you
uh are you aware that they've purchased
in a miami bookstore all this and had it
shipped over to them they've got i
certainly hope so i can use every sale i
can get do you have any idea what the
reaction is on the part of fidel castro
no no i know some journalists here i
mean it has nothing they have nothing to
do with me but i we have been calling
the cuban interest section here
and they will not make any comment
whatsoever but i'm sure
i'm sure they had it last fall because
once it got into the bound galleys i
gave a couple of the galleys to cuban
friends of mine
and within a week i heard from different
people they say everybody in miami has
read it
there's no other book like this no
there's no book like this what's
different about this book and all the
other books that have been written about
fidel castro well actually brian until
1986
in the fall there were two biographies
of fidel published both both respectable
good books not putting them down at all
but
those were the first biographies there
really were no biographies which is why
we all sort of started on them together
but neither of those books has any of
the personal material
neither of those writers went to
individual people they're more of a
compilation of the
of the other books that were published
about cuba and about the revolution and
so on you mentioned the cuban interest
section here in washington uh where is
that
well it was in the czechoslovakian
embassy until very recently and then
when the the czech liberals when
president hovel took over they asked the
cubans
uh to to leave the czech embassy now i
don't know where it is it's moved to one
of the other embassies and i'm not sure
which one it is but only a month ago or
so it's always been in the czech embassy
embassy and how does that work do we
legally represe
recognize them somehow that they can
come here yes yes we give them
permission to come but it's below the
level of an embassy we don't because we
don't recognize the cuban government we
have an embargo we don't have direct
relations so an interest section is
below the level of general diplomatic
recognition
we have an intersection in havana too
and it means you can do government to
government business but not on the same
level as a country where you have total
diplomatic relations like the swiss
embassy in cuba well we go through the
the swiss embassy yes
located exactly and i remember reading
that you said that you took out members
of the
cuban interest section here to lunch to
talk to them try to talk them into
supplying helping you with some
information yeah brian that was one of
the most interesting
stories i think of this whole book
because i was trying to
woo them in a nice way to help me get
into cuba
three nice young diplomats perfectly
pleasant people and so we were starting
lunch and they said well they said you
know we're not interested cuban people
are not interested in your book because
you're interested in fidel's personal
life and what kind of person he is and
his parents and his et cetera and he
said we're not they all said no we're
not interested in that we're not
interested we cubans are not interested
well i applied them we had about three
bottles of wine four of us
and a few hours
it's not my usual lunch hour i can tell
you
and at the end of it they were saying to
me did you say that did you say his
father was from spain did you say he had
a wife just he had children as the
father from spain angel castro who got
very rich on land
and they said do you see did you say it
other children did you say this did you
say that and i thought
my god a chill went over me and i
thought
fidel castro rules every moment of their
lives and they don't have the faintest
idea who he is what's this picture
that's fidella on a on a speedboat
is in the back in the middle and you see
brian i picked these pic i this these
pictures took me
six years to put together because
they're hard to get and i wanted
pictures of him as a human being not up
there on the plaza in a military uniform
and marching up and down like a martinet
i wanted to show fidel castro
as a human being pictures that would jar
people to think about these kinds of
leaders this picture that's his his
young wife-to-be mirta in the center
with the flowers
at her
her shower her wedding shower just
before they were married in 48 look what
a sweet beautiful
girl she is both innocent and sensuous
somehow now his father angel
and mother were born in spain uh his
father was definitely born in spain i
went twice to galicia in the northwest
to see meet i met some of adele's uncles
cousins and so on very impoverished part
of spain so the father left
came to and fought for spain in the war
of 1898 one of the first roots of
fidel's obsessive anti-americanism
angel was a very upward striving uh
he was married
that's him there that's yeah there's
angel with the the cane and the hat and
lena his wife fidel's mother next to him
and lena was the family maid angel was
married had two children and he started
sleeping with lena and they had a whole
brood of children
illegitimately and then got married when
fidel went to the catholic
school
they lived in a very simple house
lena was a
sort of annie oakley type
uh terrible housekeeper and there were
there'd be chickens and pigs all over
the house and they were so primitive
that they would they had a table but
they would eat standing up they didn't
have any chairs
and she would lena would slap all the
food on the table and the kids would
come in
and they would all eat standing up and
in later years people would say to me
after fidel became president of cuba
and say you know he is
fidel is so busy
that he can't pause to sit down at the
table he eats standing up
and i thought yeah i know why he's
standing up
and the
it the whole story of the the family was
just just quite quite incredible parents
are dead yes they're long dead and then
fidel went to the jesuit high school
again he was pushing
angel was pushing his children into the
upper class cuban society but they were
not they had money but they were not
they were lower class
and fidel when he went to the jesuit
high school
very tony spanish jesuits very
conservative
fidel's heroes were hitler mussolini and
prima de rivera the spanish phalangus
he would chart the victories of the axis
across a map
in world war ii in his room at the
jesuit high school
because he was looking for ways to power
and
he would take up the sports for instance
when they became fashionable like
basketball he was always a good athlete
and you know strong but undisciplined
but but a good athlete and he'd be
playing basketball and this came from
his basketball coach who was literally
on his death bed in florida when when i
talked to him
and
he said that he said well fidel was a
great a great sportsman but totally
undisciplined and he'd be playing
basketball on one side
and if the other team was winning and
making baskets he'd go over and play for
the other team
and
the other jesuit his jesuit mentor a
wonderful priestly father armando
yorente who was in miami and i had a
long talk with him
and i finally sent him
father did you ever see fidel praying
and he smiled and he said once in a
great while i would see him praying in
the chapel
he said i know what he was praying for
he was praying to win
[Music]
so those fathers had his number early on
after your book two is over and this
book's been out there long enough uh
what's the best thing somebody can say
to you about this whole experience
i think the best thing somebody could
say to me was
but of course
that's the way it was
and i didn't know that before
uh early in the book on page four you
say this without fidel castro's advice
and support there would have been no
nicaragua nicaragua and sandanistas
no invasion of granada
no guerilla movements from el salvador
to uruguay to chile no destruction of
democracy in the southern cone no
marxist angola mozambique or ethiopia
i i i want to say really
absolutely right when you think about it
i'm not saying
i'm very clear about that that fidel
caused all those the causes were long
there
but
fidel defined them he defined them
ideologically because he was the cat's
paw of the soviets see the soviets could
never have done any of those things
because the soviets are
persona non grata in most of those
countries the people don't like the
soviets but they like the cubans and
they like fidel he trained twenty
thousand gorillas from all over the
world they went back to those countries
became the leaders of the guerrilla
movements
his hand was the defining hand and the
deciding hand in all of those and many
more conflicts
and you also say this
he was in substantial part responsible
for the fall of nikita khrushchev for
bringing the world to the brink of
nuclear war and the missile crisis cuban
missile crisis for john kennedy's death
for the massive and threatening central
american immigration to the texas
borders for america's humiliation at the
bay of pigs there's more
and then you say by the way i got to
read the last sentence hell he even once
overthrew the government in zanzibar
one person is responsible for all this i
know it sounds it sounds extravagant but
believe me it is not
nikita khrushchev was overthrown within
the the kremlin by his own people
because of his failures in the missile
crisis there's no question all the
historians say that who got him into the
missile crisis who got missiles into
cuba it was fidel castro he was telling
khrushchev for the right after the bay
of pigs constantly the americans are
going to invade again this time it's
going to be american soldiers you've got
to protect me khrushchev wanted to put
missiles in cuba to make this
geopolitical leap to the western
hemisphere
after the bay of pigs the kennedy
brothers
particularly bobby could never give up
they had to go on trying to assassinate
fidel
the whole thing became such a bag of
worms
it without without fidel castro believe
me
none of that could would have happened
the death of john kennedy
i can't prove anything and nobody can uh
brian but when you look at the amount
the evidence
i i don't see how any discerning or
discriminating person cannot come away
without saying
the evidence points to fidel castro's
involvement lyndon johnson told four
people including my
dear friend marianne means the hearst
columnist
he told them
outright that fidel castro was behind
the kennedy assassination
again i'm not saying that fidel
personally could have caused all these
but he was the deciding hand he was
defined the guerrilla movements he
defined their ideology he made it
possible for them by giving them arms by
giving them sanctuary by giving them
training
and that is the third world
genius of this man
that he created this world of military
tactics and guerrillas and
[Music]
irregular warfare in our time by the way
an acknowledgement should say there are
a lot of things that didn't get in this
book and then you say like jose pepe
figueres's 1959 trip to cuba and you
don't tell us what it's about there's no
space here we've got three minutes what
is the story about
pepe figueres it's the classic uh story
of the peppy figures was the great
democratic president revolution then
president of costa rica very different
country from cuba middle class
free enterprise et cetera and when he
came right after to cuba right after
fidel taken over in 59
fidel just insulted him so terribly
he got up in a meeting he was supposed
to be
able to speak and fidel insulted him
the cubans shouted him down at fidel's
insistence of cars and that was the kind
of thing he did in those early days with
all of the democrats he did it with
romulo bethenko in venezuela
showing that again what the important
thing about that story and about the
others
is that fidel was never a democrat
bedell was an autocrat fidel is an
autocrat
fidel isn't a totalitarian personality
fidel is no democrat and he's no
communist and that's what those stories
show
a minute or two left
journalism
column
speeches
books
look into the crystal ball for the
future you have somebody sitting out
there right now thinking about all this
looks pretty good to them what's the
future for somebody like you younger
wants to get started in this business is
it is it a positive future well it's a
positive future brian there's plenty of
space in the foreign field
for ambitious young people who are
who have very good health and very good
feet
and
but but i would say to the kids today
don't go in it for to for upward
mobility don't go in it for your
ambition go in it for the adventure go
in for the fun go in for the excitement
follow follow what you love i always say
to young people if they say should i be
a foreign correspondent i said if you
have to ask the question
you shouldn't be it
it's like being a nun or like being a
a voodoo doctor if you don't have to do
it
don't do it because it's a calling and
it's something that you you have to love
you have to love the life you have to
love the loneliness you have to love the
the exhaustion being in other countries
the sheer fun of it best preparation
going over there learning languages
learning other cultures best uh degree
in college
journalism doesn't hurt journalism
degree lots of history lots and lots of
history so you know where you are you
know why you're where you are you know
why they're where you where they are
that was the problem in the gulf and
there weren't enough journalists there
who really knew the area
this is the book george anger is the
author guerilla prince the untold story
of fidel castro thank you very much
join us next week on booknotes for a
look at the history of network
television
our guest will be leonard goldenson
founder of abc and currently the
chairman of the executive committee of
abc capital cities
mr goldenson has spent over 30 years at
the network and has chronicled his
experiences in a book entitled beating
the odds the untold story behind the
rise of abc the stars struggles and egos
that transformed network television by
the man who made it happen
and if you would like a printed
transcript of this week's program send
five dollars to tape rider incorporated
box 885 lincolnshire illinois
60069
[Music]
c-span opens the world of issues to you
committed to bringing a complete
unedited look without commentary